how much do you worry about how you're
going to make money from filmmaking in
the next five to ten years does it
because it's one project to the next and
there's an it's not a guaranteed
you know 40-hour a week job how once you
do worry about that oh I I'm constantly
terrified about paying my bills people
tell me it's irrational but I'm
constantly terrified because it nothing
is guaranteed in the film business and I
think it's important perhaps but I do
have that health be terrified thing in
the back of my head and I've been
fortunate so far that when I'm not
directing a project I might direct an ad
campaign or I might do some kind of
commercial or do some kind of something
that's about storytelling but not
storytelling in a film so those are ways
that I pay my bills when I'm not
directing other projects but I'm always
worried about that I think that if you
ever arrive at a point where you're not
perhaps you've gotten a little
complacent because then you're kind of
this Jack Dawson on top of the world
kind of thing and the titanic's about
the head and you have no idea
you've got always be prepared and I
think that having that healthy
skepticism not only about your work but
also about your career and your future
enables you to work a little bit harder
in the present so if you're involved in
one project and you know what's going to
end on this date do you are you already
planning for the next or do you give
yourself a couple days of downtime and
then regroup like how is it that you
keep stuff in the pipeline cuz sometimes
it all it comes all at once and you
can't space it out that's true sometimes
there are moments in your career where
everything does come at once so what I
try to do if I have a big project that
I'm working on is I try to schedule
vacation in advance of the project so
say for example I have a film that ends
or a project that ends on April 10th
I might schedule a vacation to Peru or
Turkey or somewhere for two or three
weeks after that so I just step away
entirely and I make myself do it because
what I step
a that enables me to reset and refresh
and whilst I'm making that project
before I go on vacation I'm always
trying to figure out what comes after I
try not to be in a position where I have
no idea what comes next it's the same
thing
that I kind of deem as taking your
career seriously when you finish a
project whatever it is it may be a movie
an ad campaign documentary a book
whatever it is people are going to ask
you what you're doing next and if you
can't identify that or if you can't say
well here's a screenplay I wrote or
here's a project I've been developing
people don't see you is playing that
long-term game you've got to be able to
play the long-term game and really say 5
to 10 years from now this is what I want
to make this is my plan it may not come
to fruition exactly the way you expect
but if you have some kind of pathway to
get there you're going to have a lot
better chance I've heard a few people
say that they love that space of the
unknown you don't like no I do not like
the space of the unknown I think that
for me and and perhaps this has to do
with me losing my father at a younger
age unexpectedly I think that for me I
always want to have an idea of what I'm
doing next now that's not to say that
I'm not open to a project that might
come across my desk or something new
that happens all the time
but if I don't have an idea of what the
next two or three things are gonna be
that makes me panic because of the
financial reason you just talked about
because then I'm like oh my gosh I'm not
gonna be able to pay my bills I'm not
gonna be able to live in a lifestyle
that I'm comfortable with what am I
gonna do and so I think for me it's
always knowing what's going to come next
having an idea about what it is so I can
be thinking about it and plotting it
creatively talking to actors and DPS
editors my team that I like to work with
and and really understand that but if
something new comes across my desk that
can be exciting and you have to be open
to that as well okay the vacations just
as important vacation is very important
I think yeah that's true
to get yourself out it I think it's
super important I mean for me and not
everyone does it but like you know
everyone has their own thing but for me
it's when I do a big project I go
overseas I go far away for several weeks
that's for me what I do and that enables
me to really reset do you think it's
just the physical act of getting out of
LA it's it's not just about our way it's
like the u.s. in general it's like
leaving like physically picking up and
saying I'm in a foreign country and I'm
not turning myself service on it's off
and you can't reach me for three weeks
because that enables me to do a couple
of things enables me to to see things in
a different light to see another culture
and understand something I think that's
so important as a filmmaker you've got
to understand other things not just what
you're familiar with which comes back to
my upbringing a small town where I had
to always imagine things now I'm at a
place in my life where I can actually go
see things and do things and so I think
that for me that's really important it's
it's something I need its sustenance if
I if I stay one place for so too long I
feel really cagey
you